- Welcome everyone to new coffee break,
here on my channel "Firm Learning".
My name is Heinrich.
I'm a former McKinsey
consultant, and on my channel
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
And today I wanna share
with you 10 tips to communicate better,
and be perceived as
more senior on the job.
Some of these tips are
quite sneaky, quite juicy.
I can promise you that all
of them are highly effective.
So let's get into it with tip number one.
So, sometimes from a colleague or a client
you will hear an expression
or a concept that you don't know yet.
And many people will just
ask, I don't know this,
what does this mean?
Can you please explain this to me?
And of course this implies
that you have no idea
about what this is about,
you might be perceived as
not really knowledgeable.
So next time this happens to you,
try instead to say something like,
Wat does this expression mean to you?
What do you understand with this term?
Because this implies that actually
you know what this expression means,
but you even have this
higher level understanding
that sometimes different people
understand different things
with the same expression,
so you want to clarify it.
And this takes away this
notion that you have no idea
what you're talking about.
Next tip, we all know this
we already have lots of things to do,
it may be already late in the evening,
and now your supervisor, your leadership,
your team leader approaches you
and wants you to do even more.
So what a junior person might reply
to this is something
like, I just cannot do it,
I have too many things to do,
can you please ask someone
else to help you with that?
And of course, this usually
doesn't give the best vibes,
this doesn't show the best attitude.
So instead, try saying something like,
sure, let's look into this together.
Can you please help me
reprioritize my tasks
for the rest of the day?
Because this shows that yes,
you are willing to do it,
you just need the help
from the other person
to decide what the most
important things are
that need to get done today,
this evening, or this week.
Next tip, a mistake that many people do is
that they end their sentences
always on a high pitch.
So they go up with their voice
at the end of every sentence,
and this might look something like this.
So you share an idea,
and then this leads to this other thing,
and actually you also have
this other thing to share.
And then there's also this
other aspect that's relevant
and na-na-na-na, na-na-na, na-na-na-na.
So always at the end of every
sentence, the pitch goes up,
and this leaves the
people not really engaged.
This takes away gravitas,
takes away importance from
the things that you say.
Instead, try to end every sentence
with your pitch of your voice going down.
So say something like this.
I have this very important idea
that today I wanna share with you.
It is really something that will make
a big contribution to the work.
At the end of every sentence,
go down with your pitch.
This just adds gravitas
and underlines the points
that are really important.
Next tip, you might be
faced with a situation
where you really don't know what to do.
Maybe you get a task from
your leadership, but you have
no clue how to address this,
on how to structure this.
Here, again, a more junior
person might just say,
I have no clue, I really
don't know what to do,
I feel completely lost, can
you please help me with that?
And again, of course,
this often doesn't give
the best impression.
Instead, try to say something like,
I would really appreciate your insights
in helping me shape this approach.
Make it about the other person,
make it about the experience,
the insights of the other person, and now,
together, you will structure and solve
this maybe quite challenging task.
Next tip is to focus on organization
and team leadership questions.
Juniors in meetings often
very much focus on tasks,
on responsibilities, on
things that need to get done.
Well, of course, that's
very important as well.
One tip I once got is that if you wanna
be perceived as more senior,
ask more questions regarding
the organization, the team leadership.
As a leader you are responsible
for enabling your team,
for making sure that your
team is set up for success.
So ask questions exactly
in that direction.
Do we have the right
capabilities on the team?
Is this person able to lead
the project in the right way?
Can this person actually lead
and supervise this more junior colleague?
Are we working together
with the right clients?
Are we set up for success?
So these are typical questions
that more senior people will ask.
Try to do this yourself
if you wanna be perceived
this way as well.
These were the first five of the 10 tips
I wanna share with you today.
If you took any value out of them at all,
hit the like button to
help me with the algorithm.
And of course, subscribe and
turn on the notification bell
to stay up to date with my content.
But now, let's continue
with tip number six,
and this is a mistake that I often
see more junior leaders do.
And this is that whenever
there's a meeting in front
of your own internal team,
or maybe also when you talk
to clients or other external stakeholders,
this leader wants to
present him or herself.
The leader will want to give the result,
give the presentation by themselves,
and then often the team is
just sitting in the back,
listening to this junior leader present.
Try to find a set-up
where you, as the leader,
will sit in the back and
actually your team presents,
maybe not everything, but
at least some sub chapters
of the overall presentation,
of the overall meeting.
Put them in the spotlight, let them shine.
Of course, everyone knows
that you will not have
done everything yourself.
It's clear that your team will have done
a good part of the work as well.
So give them that exposure,
give them that spotlight.
And this also makes you to be perceived
as a good people leader, a
good people leader who trusts
in his or her team, a
people leader who wants
to develop his team members.
This will be perceived
as more senior as well.
Next, let's say you want to
praise someone for their job,
for their work.
And here, many people will just say,
hey, you did a good job,
thumbs up, great work.
It's great what you have accomplished.
But of course this is
not bad, it's not wrong.
Try to say something like,
thank you for your leadership
on this initiative.
Thank people for their leadership.
This is something that
I've seen very often
more senior people do.
And this of course instills also the idea
in more junior colleagues
that they are not just here
to get some work done,
but they are here to lead.
And maybe just one small initiative,
maybe just a sub part
of the overall project,
but you want people to take ownership,
take responsibility, lead
forward, make things work.
So stress this with your words
whenever you give feedback
and give praise to your colleagues
Next tip, many colleagues,
especially more junior ones,
don't really communicate that much.
They will not proactively
reach out to leadership
to share some points, maybe
in one-on-one team meetings
this is where might say something.
What I've seen many project leads do
at companies like McKinsey, BCG, Bain,
is that at the end of
every week they will write
an end of week email sharing three things.
First, the highlights of the last week,
the lowlights of the last week,
and the priorities for the next week,
and they will send this to the whole team
and their leadership.
Be a proactive communicator.
Share your thoughts, be transparent,
also things that haven't gone that great.
This as well will make you be perceived
as more senior as well.
Next tip, when someone wants
to communicate an update
on a project or any other
initiative or train of thought
that they're having, it
will often go like this,
so yeah, this is what I think,
and this is because of this reason.
And then there's also this other reason,
and, ah ya, this other
reason is important as well.
So don't do that, don't
communicate like this.
This will be perceived
as very unstructured,
instead, leverage the rule of three.
If you don't know what that it is,
I highly encourage you
to watch another video
that I will insert somewhere above here
where discuss this in detail.
But the basic idea is that
you should start always
by saying something like,
this is what I hold true
and it's because of three reasons.
So you always start by saying
that there are three
reasons for something.
First, second, and third.
Very easy structure, very effective.
Check out the other
video if you have no idea
what this might make sense.
Next tip, don't talk too fast,
and strategically use breaks,
make use of silence.
Many junior people just talk far too fast.
Talking fast is usually
perceived as being nervous
and not being safe, secure,
instead, strategically use silence.
Just sit there and say
nothing, especially after,
for instance, a client interview,
explained a couple of things
and you wanna actually hear even more.
Just say nothing.
Because for many people,
this will be uncomfortable
and often will instill the
other person to share even more.
But now I'd love to hear from you.
Do you have any other additional tips
that you'd like to share?
Leave a comment with your insights,
this would be highly appreciated.
Big, big, thanks to all
the members of the channel.
Thanks so much for your support.
My name is Heinrich, I
release weekly content.
Here next to me I will
insert some new videos
if you wanna continue
your learning journey.
All the best to you until
next week, and bye-bye.